so fun if there was a curfew system like
Bully remember
talking about that
okay thank you Moon we were talking
about that on our Tuesday night live
stream over on YouTube I did a full
video in-depth review of the game
and I don't know what do you guys think
people in the chat now because I feel
like it's one of those things that
sounds good on paper like you feel like
you would want that but imagine if every
time in Hogwarts Legacy
you were roaming around at night you had
to sneak every time
I feel like it's one of those things
that sounds really good but then once
you actually implement it it would get
annoying over time
because I I mean at first thought I I
think I agree because it's like in the
old games it was like that
but it was usually pretty easy to get to
get around things I don't know in a game
like this though where it's just free
roam you can do anything anytime
look it might might get annoying
dear Mirabelle my dear Dot
wait who's dot has been asking after you
perhaps I can convince her to stop in
for a butter beer or two if you were to
join us it's been far too long when you
do manage to come by I wonder if you'd
be able to part with a few of your
plants the more fragrant ones ever since
the troll attract attack customers have
been complaining about the smell of
Believe It or Not old socks
nothing I've tried seems to cover the
stench hoping to see you soon with or
without the plants your friends sirona
all right so this must be mirabelle's
private area here and you have the
Hufflepuff
that's a slightly different one
look at that
so these are like her private quarters I
guess
we got the little Badger right there I
do not remember seeing that on my first
playthrough
because that is definitely a slightly
different
badger
maybe that one is is meant to be from
from her time at Hogwarts slightly
different
dot is a woman from the village okay
interesting
yeah look at all these plants definitely
mirabelle's area here
take her scarf she won't mind
yeah I really thought it was so cool how
you could go into a lot of their private
studies and
get more details and more information
about the professors
all right so I think that's all we can
do in this area right now
room Raiders Hogwarts Edition I know and
and the caretaker is the one who put us
up to it
he's the one who said here go do this oh
wait that's
wrong way leading us back out
all right this one is not locked
oh we have another letter here
oh this is from the minister Professor
fig I'm in receipt of your most recent
Al apologies for the delay in my
response I'm still receiving a good deal
of Correspondence regarding the
introduction of The Not So recent
stooging penalty in quidditch which in
my humble opinion has brought the game
into the Modern Age astonishing frankly
how many Spectators want nothing less
than seeing quidditch Keepers flattened
entirely
as to the topic of your recent letter we
at the ministry assure you that any and
all potential threats to wizard kind are
taken quite seriously oh so he's
probably been reaching out to him about
the goblin threat
I've made note of your concerns and
inasmuch as time allows the department
of magical law enforcement will ensure
the matter is looked into
schedule permitting
special forbidding we value the opinions
of esteemed Wizards such as yourself and
you may rest assured that we have
matters well in hand should you wish I
can have my secretary secure seats for
yourself and a guest in this year's
quidditch final I think you would be
delighted to see the results of a
well-run and efficient government
warmest regards Ferris
Minister for magic I used to say spaven
and then I think I heard I think it's
fig who says
spavin at some point
Damia welcome in
Sea Dog I see you right there
what do I think about the delay oh I
didn't respond to that because we we had
just talked about that delay when you
asked about it
I thought you probably heard my response
because your question came so quick
after it
yeah we talked about that right at the
beginning of the Stream
builds would have a stroke
level two lock right there
we can't get in there yet
so this must be
this must be figs area right here
all right upstairs we go
casting revelio reveals authority
figures in enemy locations allowing you
to scout ahead and remain undetected
[Music]
see I I honestly wish we were talking
about Stealth and sneaking around
earlier
I don't know that I would want it to be
that way every single time but I do wish
there were more
situations and scenarios like this right
here
where stealth is is needed reminder to
staff the Hogwarts house elves do an
exceptional job of keeping the castle in
order they are seldom unprepared for any
number of items that they might
encounter each day however only the
other day an unexpected stash of wizard
crackers went off from behind a cushion
the cacophony
cacophony I think that's how that's
pronounced was most untoward engulfing
one poor elf in blue smoke and giving
those of us nearby an abominable ringing
in our ears for the rest of the day I
expect that the culprit was peeves
please keep an eye out and be careful
Matilda Weasley deputy headmistress
right like it's just this section and
then that one Mission with Sebastian in
the library
use L2 and R2 to lure unsuspecting
enemies
oh maybe have stealth like just to sneak
out and once you're out like outside the
castle
oh it's all good Sea Dog it's all good
yeah no worries
yeah we were just saying like it's
unfortunate that there's a delay but
hopefully it will result in a better
game
and we did have over on our YouTube live
the other night we had one of the
developers working on the game actually
stopped by
and said they had been playing the PS4
version and that it was shaping up
nicely So for anybody who was
who may be worried just know that it on
their end it sounds like things are
progressing they just need a little bit
more time
oh look at this little area this is cool
wait is that the one that people think
looks like Snape
there's one I know in the room of
requirement
I could see it a little bit I could see
it a little bit
I don't know that it was intended for
that purpose though
if that's the exact same one all right
we have another letter right here
my darling Abraham you would be
overjoyed to know that the local
children have taken to playing gobstones
in the street just wait A and M
[Music]
aren't those the same
I think those are the same initials that
we found last time there was a letter in
the room of requirement A and M
because I think is is ronan's wife
does her name start with an m
you'd be overjoyed to know that the
local children have taken a plane
gobstones in the street just outside of
your study window they're quite Charming
I must say I noticed the youngest was
without her own set of gobstones so I
lent her one of yours I knew you
wouldn't mind wait I just had the
thought does that mean that
when schools in session that the
the Wizards and witches who have spouses
they don't
they they live without them for that
huge chunk of the year
no way right like when you have
operating why wouldn't they just
maybe they go home every night
with operating anything is possible
Right
I do hope things are going well at the
castle I'm relieved that you arrived
safely Dreadful story about the
gentleman from the ministry was he
really traveling with Eleazar and a
student simply Dreadful do write when
you have a moment I'm most eager to hear
your stories of this year's summoner's
Court participants your students so
adore you my dear with love M yeah I
mean the way she's writing this it's
like they're not gonna see each other
for
months until there's a break
okay so this is ronan's area
it makes little sense
they could do it one of two ways right
like when you have apparating the
professors could just operate in every
day now I know you can't operate onto
the Hogwarts grounds but it shouldn't be
too hard you know apparate just outside
and then you just walk on into work for
the day or they have these huge private
quarters where they seemingly sleep so
why not just have the spouses come and
hang out with them and then if they have
somewhere else to go to work then they
just leave each day
hold on we've we've found an
inconsistency here
the bogart cabinet wait in here
in ronan's area
oh right there
you think that's actually meant to be
the bogart cabinet
or is that just where Ronan keeps his uh
clothing
I do love all of ronan's decorations I
mean
clearly reflects his love of all things
like fun and games
Tempest in a bottle right there
after it would make our lives so much
easier right
a letter in Black's room saying the kids
miss him yes I do remember seeing that
one
from his wife
yeah yeah like from inside but I mean
they could walk out
walk off the grounds you know I feel
like
I feel like there's a very easy way
around that
all right I don't think we need to go in
there just yet
we're on the lookout for
Two Moons I think he said oh
but first
no lock on
there we go
it looks the same but that's not yeah I
was I was thinking oh
I did not get caught on my first
playthrough
oh dude
he was not having it
yeah I think he's up here talking with
Weasley
rather poorly I'd say let's listen in
let's listen in
we're raising a generation of coddled
Cape Flappers that can scarcely tell the
difference between us hate Flappers yes
well
still early perhaps they'll improved
say that every year
optimistic pessimistic much
yeah see dog we've this is our second
playthrough
I thought that was
we Press On
yeah we're about
let's see what are we level 17 on this
playthrough I think yeah level 17. on
this playthrough I am focusing way more
on story
okay let's see if this
he's not even looking oh no no no no no
[Music]
go on that way
it's got a field guide page to collect
my friend Revenue I think you have one
right here too yeah
Boris the bewildered the statue of a
lost looking wizard known as Boris the
bewildered has perplexed students for
ages is he coming or going is he at the
beginning of a journey or the end
perhaps we shall never know
or is the bewildered
is he at the beginning of a journey
I'm gonna say beginning I mean he looks
like he's afraid to even start though
he looks afraid to start
Marielle welcome in welcome in
to be the brief Ed both from
revex bathroom I mean we can go ahead
and go in here oh there is one in here
right I think there's one in here
I believe there is a moon here
just completely on the other side yeah
there it is oh man we got a lot of
students over there though
turn on the water
all right let's do this let's
wait no I wanna
prefix
there you go somebody go investigate
[Music]
oh man the sneaky Slytherin prefect
did not see her coming Clint welcome in
Clint how's it going
Simeon first time I got caught was the
prefix bathroom wait that's
[Music]
dude we should have had that
I just did not see that one at all
yeah yeah we already know this
all right we hadn't found any of them
yet because we've been taking our time
just exploring everything
oh they've changed positions right here
okay so that's fine we've already went
in there
we'll get the arithmancy door later I'm
not worried about it right now
apparently we missed that though
oh and hold on Sharp and Weasley are not
here anymore either
jewel encrusted tortoise shell many
assumed assume this to be the shell of a
fire crab native to Fiji however those
in the know swear it's a Bejeweled
tortoiseshell created by a mad wizard
near
Versailles
when his Chateau was overrun by nifflers
the dazzling shell was carried off to be
discovered Years Later by a Hogwarts
Professor on holiday in the art ardins
I don't I have no idea how to say that
last word ardenese ardins
all right and that one's a level three
lock so we can't get in there for a
while
yeah it did detect when you said troll
it thought you were uh
calling someone someone else that
Auto mod on top of it
hey it's Sea Dog with the hydrate there
also I see some a new follow there
welcome in to the new follows
all right so
you need to go
over there
okay fine just go on upstairs that that
works too sir
just ignore the portrait that moved
right there it's all good let's be the
prefix bathroom
all right we need to see exactly how
many they have in here
oh no I didn't mean to do that
all right so
I see one two three wait how can you see
me already no shot
okay you go to investigate
are they where'd the
okay so yeah then the other two are
still over there
anyway all right got the Moon
I'm gonna do why don't you leave
I want to turn on one of these there we
go
prefix bathroom the prefix bathroom
features a swimming pool size bathtub
that can be filled with Enchanted soap
and colorful bubbles as well as a
beautiful painted mural depicting a
mermaid
level one lock right there
oh man what do you think should we
should we go for it oh
foreign
just wait in here we'll be very quiet
guys
go swim I can't right now I'm on the
stealth mission
oh no he's right outside there now
I want to open up this chest
we're just
relaxing here on the stall
oh no imagine if he just stays there oh
and look at that that looks like
oh I think that's another Demi guys on
the floor above
you hitting the stall too
no
close the door
please
what are you doing dude close the door
come on man oh man he's coming he's
following me quickly
all right there we go we unlocked that
let's go ahead and get this field guide
page
oh I forgot to read it unicorn Fountain
oh no
I do remember this part right here
I suppose oh man we got it no no we're
dead we're done
we're done
I had planned to bet a few galleons
oh man
all right so we've got to go back now we
just got caught in the hospital Wing I
promise you guys my first playthrough I
did not get caught at all
did not get caught at all now that's
what our second time already
I think I'm just being too uh LAX
all right
just going straight bye I'm disappointed
about crazy please be quiet student
don't say anything
all right now we just wait here but
first should we try and distract them
like should we get them to go
investigate over there
did I just hit
I think we just hit Professor heck out
with that
that was not into
I was trying to make it just fly right
by
you know what I'm gonna be extra bold I
thought I'm gonna go after this right
here
why can I not lock on there we go
no way
oh no
flying about and the Golden State go
I don't know where the nurse is
oh
oh my goodness we made it
we made it
okay
all right I think that's all we needed
to get for our buddy Gladwin
now we just have to go back and tell him
yeah this is such a fun area to explore
such a fun area to explore especially
when you come back later
this guy doing how long does he just no
no
you out
my goodness
hold on do we even have to go back
though we should still have the moons so
we should just be able to tell glad oh
of course it puts us back in here
of course it does
hey Trisha thank you so much for the two
months
appreciate that very much Trisha enjoy
your ad free viewing and guys if you're
if you're a sub here check out the new
animated emotes
we were spamming those early at the
start of the Stream
okay that time it was a lot easier I
guess it was just a matter of better
timing
let's make our way all the way back to
the bottom okay there's one more let's
see can we just sneak right behind you
that's what I'm gonna try to do
[Music]
good I think we're in the clear hold on
is this a level one no it's not why am I
even wasting my time right now
I just need to get back to Gladwin and
complete this mission
yeah there you go Simeon
yeah we are playing on hard mode as well
this is hard mode yep
all right Gladwin hello Mr Moon I have
we got it you asked me to collect oh
[__] some light on who's behind all this
of course I first suspected peeves the
previous caretaker to an early
retirement with his intolerable
buffoonery
but that does not explain the bogart he
knocks me does it
you discover the identity of my
Tormentor
if I have the time I'll see what I can
do but I'm fairly don't make promises I
can't promise anything um
yeah the hype one I love the hype one
too
change for your
now remember the moons are only
retrievable at night thus I encourage
you to use a disillusionment witness and
lots of revelio to find the moons lots
and lots of revelios
all right I understood I shall keep an
eye out I appreciate that
all right Gladwin
so now any moons that we find in the
castle
we can start collecting them
so we'll do cross ones here and then
we'll see if we can open that up yet
your Champion indeed let's go Lucan
Transfiguration thanks Ryan that's what
I was thinking all right Lucan I think
we have to do something with the
training dummy too
hello Lucan is the final round of cross
ones ready big
all right hard mode I don't know if it
makes cross wands any harder but
we're doing it
ready for a shot I'm ready
nope I'll go it's alone solo
further increase the challenge
oh it's Leander
Sharla and speaking of Nelly I think
that's Nelly right there
dude 4v1
or V one
it's all right we got this
There Goes My Way really
oh my goodness
come on it's a little bit too late
like a winner
okay this is pretty tough they have a
lot of uh oh wait we meant to use all of
the okay what do they want us sharp
wanted us to use something at the same
time
I think it was the I think it was Maxima
and
the adoras okay so we just use a duras
in the program
now we use Maxima nope wrong one
all right we got Charlotte out of the
picture
Victory let's go
can't remember if we have to go again or
not or if that's it
oh that's it we won
I'm just getting started there's nothing
I'm just getting started if the best due
list in the school weren't enough
competition then perhaps you should
consider transferring to Durham
strengths now to the victor goes
I think it's robes right to present you
thank you thank you it's been an honor
you end
ickened with now that we've definitively
crowned the tournament winner I was so
disappointed there weren't wasn't more
cross once after this I have intended
them in ages I thought it was going to
be a recurring thing that just kept
happening throughout the school year but
it just ends that's just it
that's it right there
what do you think about that Leander I
cannot
shame it's over but here's Nelly right
here
let's go ahead and unlock this while
we're here
once we just unlocked
alohomora
[Music]
oh same place
I know the Halloween decorations
very nice
that's one another little quality of
life thing I'd love to see is if we
could if they could add where we could
jump to any
season
because just to see all the different
decorations even after you've beaten the
game
new game plus stuff like that man it's
actually pretty dark back here
pretty dark in this stairwell
oh yeah this is a cool puzzle right here
I can't remember if we can solve this
yet
see will glacias work on it or do we
need a Resto momentum
oh glaciers will work okay cool because
the first time I solved it I used a
Resto momentum but looks like glacias
will work just as well
Rebellion
let's grab that field guy page while
we're here
oh wow glacias holds it for a while look
at that
New Game Plus yes
they need it for sure I would love to
see a new game plus added
see it's so easy to get sidetracked oh
my goodness that stays much longer
let's see do I actually have to
wow okay if you guys haven't done that
puzzle yet it it is much better to use
glacias
because arresto momentum wears off I'm
pretty sure Resto momentum wears off but
that glacias was holding for a while
so you basically like you can look at
the little uh the symbol on the doors
here
it's like see this one looks kind of
like a little
heart at the top
it's this one right here
so when it comes by we need to stop it
right here
and now
this door should remain open
you use the rest of my momentum as well
yeah that's I totally thought that's
was probably the best choice but
I guess not
Rebellion
all right we got a new wand handle from
that right there
okay and then let's see where's the next
one
I think the other one
is it up high is it is there another
level that's right there's another level
here
okay that one
I don't even know how to describe that
looks like a little man sitting on his
like sitting on his side
okay
to facing the left facing the left
this one right here that's the one
can bring us
wow I wonder how long it stays when you
use glaciers maybe you have to
I'm sure if you leave and come back it
will eventually
all right now because I remember doing
it yeah with a Resto I kind of had to
hurry a little bit to make it up up to
that spot right there oh
legendary chest right here
Kellen welcome in dude how's it going
yeah one more for advanced tips and
tricks exactly
unidentified face item right there
you've been wondering how Professor
spells to keep it
keep it from changing back
yeah my first like I said my first try
or my first playthrough I used a Resto
on both of them or all of them because
there's more than just those two
okay so we already got that one
I know there's two more
okay I think they're down though let's
go down
oh finally it just wore off
wow so glacias I mean it holds for a
while okay we need that one kind of
looks like a little face of an owl
all right right here
is that and then this one will open up
oh no
all right hold on let me go out
he even opened his eye when the door
opened
Jimmy guys in The Portrait or in the
tapestry right there
Hogwarts Legacy TV welcome in how's it
going
Kellen still can't believe we were
speaking about this game Non-Stop and
now it's here in our hands I know
not only in our hands for many people
already beaten and moved on
it's crazy after all the years of
waiting
so yeah this is my second playthrough
of which I'm sure there will be there
will be many more in the future I don't
know if I'll play through it again
immediately after this one
but
okay and then I think there's one final
spot
at the bottom that we can unlock with
this
revelio let's see is it you nope you're
another
is it I think it's this one right here
yes it is the Unicorn
all right where is the unicorn at
right there is the Unicorn
okay so we'll wait for it to swing back
wait Luke is still showing a quest
oh no I don't know if that's over far
enough
yes it still worked perfect
okay the door
I don't know what happened with the door
right there
solve Hogwarts Secrets challenge
complete hold on what do we get out of
that right there
conjuration large natural Terrain
nothing else in this one
dude
it never fully opened look at this
oh my goodness that's crazy
I'm afraid to keep doing it because I
don't want it to glitch and lock me in
there
look on the floor whoa where at Ryan
where should I look on the floor back in
that room
how long does it take you to play
through it that's a tough one because
I could I'll tell you on this second
playthrough I could have went through a
lot faster if I wasn't watching all the
cutscenes but because we're you know
we're streaming it live and I realize
some people may be watching it for the
full experience and we're posting it
over on YouTube as well so I want to
watch the cutscenes but the cut scenes
can get pretty long like if you skip
those
I'm not gonna say you can cut the time
in half but I don't know maybe buy a
third buy a fourth if you're skipping
skipping the cut scenes
but yeah my first playthrough of doing
everything it was a 100 play through was
right around 80 hours since I did
right around 80 hours
challenge ready and keep in mind I was
also doing a lot of playing to capture
footage for content to make videos and
stuff so that's brilliant one that's
certainly why mine's probably a little
bit higher because some people I think
were able to do 100 and 60 hours or so
you need to stop
both are also on the floor I see now yes
Indio levioso
[Music]
okay
there it is all right so
one two three
yeah I can see why they teach you that
one it's almost a must Before You cast
cast incendio
cooldown
no no no
oh my goodness
it's a long combo right there
take some time to get through it yeah it
does
I couldn't have done it without you it
was just a dummy
I was only a training dummy but it's a
difficult dummy believe me I know
seriously well done training dummies
will think twice before challenging you
again yeah I wish they would have taught
even more combos good point I haven't
stopped training stay sharp my friend
but then I also oh that's tough because
I also kind of like the idea of
experimenting on your own finding them
on your own
all right I really want to finish the
daily in Keys Quest I might do that off
stream actually
that way the next time we play I'll have
I'll have that robe ready to go
best robes in the game anybody who
doesn't know the
the robes that you get for completing
the the daily and keys Quest
so cool
it's a it's kind of a lengthy Quest
unless you know exactly where to find
everything which we have a YouTube video
up for that
if you don't mind like if you some
people want to find them on their own I
get that I respect it but if you want to
just get straight to the wait what has
happened here
what
how do these fish end up here
I have so many questions
so many questions I don't know if there
was a storm or what Rebellion
all right so wait you're already at your
destination load gok what am I supposed
to be doing buddy
I don't even remember
hey welcome in Stephy you did all the
things too nice good luck good luck to
everybody who entered recover the helmet
from the thieves well did I not
I thought we searched everything that we
could here
you're already at your destination
cover the helmet from the thieves
oh maybe we just have to like explore
this whole little area here because I
see the map it's like oh there we go oh
wait
oh I want that there we go oh I just
apparently the barrel was blocking our
path
fair enough
there it is and of course now we have
more people showing up for an attack
perhaps it's been
Infinity
these are level 20.
no sir you're not getting away that easy
by myself
you have uncollected rewards oh let's
see what we got in the rewards
I know what was going on with those fish
there's been a few things I've seen on
my second playthrough that I never saw
in my first playthrough
or maybe I should say I don't remember
seeing on my first playthrough and that
right there was one of them I do not
remember that
do not remember that
a JW welcome in thank you for the follow
okay we do have another talent that we
unlocked one Talent Point available
and as you can see we are adding a lot
more to the dark arts tree this time
all right so that's actually all we can
upgrade on there right now because we
don't know any of the unforgivables just
yet
let's see what we have over here ooh
glacias upgrade where's the defender
upgrade I'm Gonna Save that because we
just unlocked
that Quest from Sharp
all right we need to return the helmet
to load gawk and then then return to
Professor sharp and he will teach us
defendo which one of my favorite spells
in the game one of the most powerful
spells in the game I would say
all right take me back to load guck
is he just up here
Marielle thank you for stopping by have
a good one
it's just on the other side
never stopped me before there he is
I retrieved the helmet from the
ashwinders well done this is sure to
impress ran Rock the helmet shines even
more brightly than sure to impress the
etchings the Contour of the profile
remarkable
looks like it just looks like a helmet
to me ah you're looking at one of these
rather than what it means to most
goblins this is more than a mere helmet
you did the thieves hey welcome back
Professor spells I know many a goblin
who would have killed for it ah then I'm
glad to be rid of it myself thank you
this should earn ranrock's trust I will
take it to him immediately it may
distract him from his search his search
it does it is million inkling will it
though greatly friend I'm glad that I
trusted you
will it though we shall speak soon
best to keep our Arrangement quiet for
now many will not believe that our aims
might possibly be aligned
and right after that Elwyn redeeming a
IRL word ban
Elwyn has selected the word
Magic
so for the next 15 minutes here ladies
and gentlemen
boys and girls people of the internet
witches and wizards Muggles of all ages
welcome to everybody's favorite 15
minutes in retro raconteur's live
streams
the 15 minutes when we have a banned
word
that we cannot say
we still don't have any punishment for
it yet but people still love laughing at
me anyway
so they repeatedly do this okay so we
should be able to learn
defendo now let's see if we completed
that Quest okay we got Sebastian we can
do that next and that one is required
we have to do that
the elf the knapsack and the loom
Zeke wants to teach me how to use the
knapsack to rescue
certain beasts
I would argue that's a different word
than our band word but it does have that
word in it
we'll be very careful
all right let's go ahead and do this
first so we learned defendo
all right Hogwarts
back to Sharp down in the potions
classroom
hey while I'm here
oh no we need to go back to room of
requirement to get those
assignments
I finished the toss yes sir well well I
trust you are meticulous in your efforts
after all shortcuts only ever lead to
shortcomings
I don't like your tone Sharp
don't like it of course good
ordinarily I'd say it's not my concern
either way but you
I want to make sure you're well prepared
well thank you
combination appreciate it would be a
shame to let that go to waste thank you
professor don't let it go to your hand
no let's see how you fare with defindo
wand at the ready
oh man my mom is here I don't know what
she is cooking but it smells very tasty
foreign
defendo guys don't sleep on it
followed by glacias
one of the most powerful spells in the
game I would encourage you see I've been
leaving a slot for it for your sake
right there
does have a bit of a cool down on it
though
let's go
to my fingers as I mentioned earlier
but dangerous
we got it sharp we got it under control
okay now let's take a look at our next
Quest here
meet Sebastian and feldcraft
theek wants to teach me how to use the
navsec oh we we kind of need to go in
there anyway
so I'm gonna do that one first
and then we'll we'll go to feldcroft
okay secret rooms
room of requirement I think has seen one
of these before thank you sir
whoa Deke trying to capture me
it's like he's seen the future he knows
Lord retromore perfect for Gathering
goes on to become an incredibly powerful
wizard
not having it Deke
I have been thinking about something
Professor Howard said in BEAST's class
that I should study as many beasts as I
can on my own time she also mentioned
that poachers have been active in the
area
so
perhaps the beasts will be safer with us
than out on their own precisely what the
heck was thinking you see the room knew
exactly what you needed and luckily deed
can show you how to best use the
knabsack and where
all right Deek show me
wait is this when you unlock vivariums
our first stop will be beyond the castle
grounds we can leave now or you can come
and find dick when you're ready to go
okay hold on Deke before we do that I
need to collect this
dude this is hard mode I actually have
to
make sure we're Brewing the wig and weld
potions and we definitely need to
upgrade this too we need to get the
large one where we can have a bunch
going at one time all right no
unidentified gear
I also need to buy the hopping pot
hopping pots are really really good in
this game
Loom is the biggest game changer yeah
all those upgrades and the
extra properties you can start putting
on things
that was a dog Time indeed's Life Dick
found himself in service of the crudest
wizard he ever met a nasty poacher dick
hated working for him it's funner than
being a dark wizard I don't know yet
I've not been one yeah in those days
Patrick saw a knob sack
it'll be nice to see one used for good
the Lord retro Mort has been born now to
take over the Wizarding World
that is what this playthrough is all
about
Deacon Joy's coming here to watch the
beasts especially the Buffalo schemes
nearby it would be nice to keep them
safe all you will need to do is get
close direct the open knapsack toward
the puff skin and in it'll go all right
Okay so we've got to map that first
all right puff skin
these are pretty easy to get
how many do you want Deke how many do we
need
Autumn thank you for the follow
do you need more I don't think he cares
I think he just needed one right
she's gonna go ahead and get a few
okay
chat says we don't even have we don't
even have the first unforgivable yet
but that's what we're about to start
that next our
we have a new Quest from Sebastian it's
not the one where you get crucio yet but
it will move us one step closer to that
one step closer to that moment
everything's all right now
all right Deke are you happy
we got five for you buddy I managed to
rescue a puff skin you can rescue as
many as the knapsack will hold poachers
capture poof schemes and well Deek isn't
sure what they do with them dick is
certain they will be safer with you much
safer with us much safer deep suggests
you next find a beast that can fly a job
and all perhaps all right where would I
find one dick knows of some to the West
nesting in a large tree overlooking
Hogwarts no we have to go do that too
Casino poachers in the area recently
dick will meet you there whenever you're
ready
oh we want that Loom Deke so we will
meet you there
all right let's fly a little bit I
haven't got a chance to just look at the
scenery in a while
that is one thing that I don't think
will ever get old of this game
just being able to hop on the broom at
any time
and fly around this just incredible
world that they've created
all right while we're over here
you guys see what I'm eyeing don't you
you see what I'm buying
we gotta go ahead
Stargazer Tim what's up welcome in
looking at recipe for puff skin Puff
cakes yes yes safer
in quotes with me indeed
puff scheme Puff cakes I don't even want
to ask about that
don't even want to ask about that one
all right so that is three four
troller
thank you for the follow my friend
welcome in
oh no battery low
hold on I couldn't see though did I have
okay yeah I did have the notification
I couldn't see if the notification
popped up or not saying that we had them
all
right we'll see how much longer we have
on this battery
you plug it up if I need to but
I prefer the freedom of keeping it
Wireless
oh good a dick was worried about you
what with all the poachers in the area
perhaps we should work quickly the
jobanols are just here in this large
tree if it's helpful Deek has seen
levioso use two slow flying beasts
that's right getting close and use the
knapsack
levioso
let's see levioso
let's just do it let's just do it good
luck dick will be waiting oh my goodness
look at these comments Tim what have you
done
thestral legs are young are yummy
wow
there's there's dark Wizards and then
there's dark Wizards
you guys
oh my goodness
I don't even remember how many he said
we needed
some home I mean you know um
imagine though imagine oh no
come on one and two
all right that's two that should be
enough for him
believe this
is that good for you Deke oh no
I don't realize you're about to fall off
right there
I rescued the Japanese Deke hopes your
job and all finds the knapsack nice sex
cozy poachers want them for that hey
that are not kind when they gather them
timer is up any other beasts nearby
banned word is complete
you can say magic again guys that was
our band word
goodness Deke
there's not enough space
of course there is
that was a nice try Tim too I saw it Tim
asking me does the controller run on
Magic
it was a good try it was it was a good
attempt good attempt
hello deek
mentioned it
together 15 minutes is way too short you
try it Dustin you try it out of the moon
so unfortunately unless you have a way
to haste in time you might sometimes
have to wait it just so happens
I do have a way to hasten time
you guys know what I just realized we
completely forgot that other Moon
in the back of the hog's head completely
forgot about it we'll be waiting for
your return
all right Advanced time you should be
proud first let's go on over here though
Oh wait we're here is this it
oh yeah I do I remember this in my first
playthrough
all right let's do weights and we're
going to advance
all right Moon caps I mean you know home
not going to hurt you that
that little Moon calf
no not lumos
let's go ahead and get two
I want to look off to you
we won't
Lord retro more it won't our first
playthrough
retro reckons who are absolutely will
look after them
actually he might because I didn't see
the moon cops dancing it's a marvelous
once he sees that he can use them
because you have finished here he'll be
able to he probably would take care of
them but for now let's bring the ones
you've gathered back to the room all
right geek will meet you back in the
room whenever you're ready yes then it's
time to unlock the
the loom of improvement
all right back to Hogwarts is lumos the
new orleo no I just
I'm not used to this uh spell setup just
yet
and honestly I'm just not used to having
the
the Beast bag on much anyway
there you go okay we need to show the
Beast you rescued then you home he's
about to open up our first vivarium but
um not enough room to let them out here
it's running a mark
perhaps if you focus on what your beasts
need the room will provide
here we go
[Music]
foreign
what exactly did you think of
a loom with a view I love it Tim
deke's so surprised
you told me what to do dude
isn't sure
only one way to find out
come on Duke you knew this was gonna
happen when you're ready
you knew
all right let's go on in why did they
leave out the Yule Ball and Triwizard
Tournament so try wizard tournament it
wouldn't have been a Canon for this time
period
look at this if you remember it was a
big deal and Goblet of Fire because they
were bringing it back
that was their first attempt in a really
long time
that's probably why they didn't they
didn't do it for the game it will be
quite comfortable
I don't know if I'd say it was banned
but at some point they stopped doing it
let them see the new
release them let them see their new home
all right
one of each
adventurous little elf
the jabernal
dick thinks the vivarium will be a
fitting new home for your beasts indeed
I only hope we'll have enough space for
all of them no shot Deke would trust a
wizard that looks like my guy
hogsmeade will help to find safe
yes we can name them after Voldemort's
Death Eaters have a beasts in need and
she'll give you a fair price for them
care beasts that are well fed and
groomed will provide you with valuable
magical materials valuable materials
there we go for example
yeah there's some magical materials from
your beasts dee can show you how to use
them very well I shall let you know when
I have some
all right when magical beasts are
nurture yeah we know about this
so we need the feed I guess he wants us
to do this for the mission
most excellent
where's the other ones
right there
here have some food
[Music]
Beast isn't ready
well you better get ready Lord retro
Mort does not have time eat your food or
you get nothing
all right where's the jabernal hey you
do you want to eat yeah that's right you
better get over here
you better get over here
okay wait what do you still need you
still need to be fed
all right you're good
and you needs to be rushed
about now
no not you again
you've already had a brush you
Force feet
we're not force-feeding them
all right Deke are you happy now I
collected some magical materials dick
now Deke can show you how to use them
yes time for the loom let's go use this
spellcraft to conjure an enchanted Loom
an enchanted Loom exactly it will allow
you to use your magical materials to
weave magic into the very threads of
your clothing making your clothing more
useful in a variety of ways why don't
you try it dig things you'll be
impressed that's the only reason we did
this dick that's the only reason with
the loom now so please
all right collection updated with the
enchanted Loom
oh hey and we even got a a trait for it
too
okay so we need to
this right here wow and we really do not
have a good spot for it I'm just gonna
put it right in the middle of the floor
okay it's under utility
Enchanted Loom
oh this is a terrible spot for it man
it needs to be close to the
oh wait right here will this work yeah
there we go
and let's go ahead and make it green
just to match everything else for our
for our Slytherin play through here
all right gear features one primary
offense or defense stat by default
magical materials can be used with the
loom to add and upgrade a secondary Stat
or apply traits to your gear multiple
small upgrades can yield a meaningful
boost in combat power newbies can be
rescued at Beast dens or unlocked in
quests new trait recipes can be
collected in Bandit camps
all right now
are we finally good can we finally move
on
wonderful will I be able to weave even
more powerful magic into my clothing
with the loom you will I risk you
getting even more getting so excited for
this for now however big suggestions can
already feel the power and get to know
the Beast you've already rescued
thank you for your help Deke
all right I think
I think that's it
yep there it is complete main quest
eight out of eight
so that's going to unlock something else
in our challenges right here okay we can
do quests right there
all right so we unlocked the mask
top of the class ensemble
all right Sebastian where are you at
buddy
you made it
enjoying the view keeping an eye on
things
feldcraft isn't what it used to be no
one has felt safe here since ranrock's
loyalists took a peculiar interest in
that castle Over The Rookwood Castle my
uncle Solomon is a former Aura and
refuses to look into it even after Anne
was cursed by one of them possibly with
a wand no less I heard a goblin refer to
wizard kind as wand carriers
a Goblin's forbidden from carrying ones
precisely that's why I'm on the hunt for
answers if I'm secure her I need to
understand what happened to her Anne was
always the most mischievous of the three
of us
which is saying something knowing me
Anonymous that is hard to believe prize
visit from me and a new friend from
Hogwarts will help lift her spirits
bring back the annihoustoner come on
I'll take you to my uncles
obviously when we see her we're seeing
her in a very different state than she
is normally but
more full of mischief than Sebastian
wowcroft used to be a lot livelier
with Round Rock slots wandering about
all the time everything stays out lead
the way
when I see another field guy page here
we are hold on Sebastian just inside
it's going to be too far out of the way
no it is not
hey thank you so much for the five bits
right there
dubeck alms OMSI TTV
appreciate it appreciate it and thank
you to the new follows as well so we had
a couple new follows right there
as we just hit Level 20.
all right Sebastian let's do this guys
if you haven't played through the game
yet this is our first introduction to
Sebastian's Uncle Solomon and whoo
he's not really
this whole family situation it's a
really tough situation and the more
layers that peel back to it even worse
it is we just posted a YouTube video as
well if you guys haven't seen it like a
deep dive
into the character of Sebastian
all right here we go
Sebastian where did you oh she says
triple fix cannot reverse a curse
here's the uncle the sooner you accept
that reality the better
when will you accept that never I can
never I mean he just walked in
blaming Sebastian
I'm sorry you have to see that
if you don't mind I just need a moment
to learn robes glitching out of business
he died for like the uncle could have
totally changed the whole trajectory of
this
just with a little bit more frame my
last name love
just just a little bit
just a little compassion a little
empathy would have went a long way
excuse me Mr Salo oh yes Sebastian's
friend I apologize on behalf of my
nephew he doesn't know when to stop
he thinks he can help Anne but nothing
could be done for her
[Music]
if I say surely in my first playthrough
I said surely there's something and he
snaps back at me
I want to see what happens if I say I'm
so sorry I understand you've tried
everyone from nurse Blaney to some
mongos to no avail we have
my nephew thinks he knows better than
the healers
these days I think so oh Sebastian is
wait because I'm finding a way to help
his sister
if there is a cure he's gonna snap Now
find it your faith in Sebastian is
misplaced
a little bit of dark magic cursed Anne
and the Goblins aren't likely to explain
themselves anytime soon giving her hope
is cruel
the only thing to do now is keep and
comfortable and stay out of the
loyalist's way
I understand what you're saying sir good
I know what's best for Anne and
Sebastian
they are my stubborn Brothers children
hmm especially Sebastian talking bad
about
what he wants to do his no idea the harm
he could do if he doesn't stop
or shadowing foreshadowing if you
remember
good day
foreshadowing a little bit
I'm sorry about earlier those bouts of
pain are difficult to bear
are you all right Anna I didn't mean to
intrude you didn't
Umbridge Vibes I'm all right a little
bit pain from this curse comes in bouts
and often suddenly
anyone's fault it's nice to meet you by
the way you must be the new fifth year
Sebastian told me about I am Sebastian
and I met on my first day at Hogwarts in
the Slytherin common room oh the common
room
I adore teasing First Years about
spotting mermaids through the window
I do miss Hogwarts that's slightly
different dialogue since I'm in
Slytherin if it wasn't so dreary now I
think the Goblins at the castle and my
uncle fighting with Sebastian whenever
he's home
it's not the Cozy Retreat it once was
Sebastian mentioned something about your
uncle being an ex-ora but refusing to go
after ranrock's loyalists I must say I
wasn't prepared for him to be as angry
as he was Uncle Solomon is frustrated
by what happened to me and by Sebastian
for thinking he can fix it they both
mean well I know they do but my uncle is
right this curse cannot be undone that
was the moment for me Sebastian cannot
take away my
when she tells you
when she tells you that look I know
nothing can be done
[Music]
I'll do my best
I can promise to speak with him about it
thank you you search for a cure as
futile I'm afraid I'm getting tired I
should probably rest thank you for
stopping by
I wish you well I ought to see how
Sebastian's faring
then you also can find some fun little
notes
that one from Seb to Anne Dear Ann
Hogwarts isn't the same without you well
sharp is still as foul but you know what
I mean hope you're feeling better
Sebastian
and then one over here from her to him
Sebastian this is my potion kit not
yours leave my things be
all right now we go back outside and
talk to him
why will he not listen to me she's my
sister
how are you doing Sebastian you got a
first-hand glance at what I'm dealing
with
I apologize for my uncle I love how they
both they're both apologizing for each
other I'll admit I wasn't expecting him
to be so angry he's always angry
he's been angry since my parents died
after Anne was hurt he only grew worse
it's as though he blames me somehow
always calling me my Father's son as if
that's an insult I'm the one trying to
help her he's simply given up both Anne
and your uncle seem genuinely convinced
that nothing more can be done for her I
refuse to believe that Anne's pain is
more than physical it has changed her
entirely I miss my sister
and I'm going to get her back come with
me I need to show you where it happened
see like all that right there Round
Rock's loyalists are capable of so much
more than people realize they should not
be underestimated
look Sebastian makes some very bad
choices in this game but that whole
scenario right there that's abandoned a
state dude did nothing wrong
that Uncle just
completely destroyed that whole
situation
up there on that plateau
is where they care Stan oh my goodness
Luna released
she's just like
she can't stand it Luna's my dog guys
anybody new here doesn't know
all right I'm Gonna Save the most recent
gameplay too I want to save that
that cut scene make sure I get that
cutscene that we just
saw being played
I know the uncle just totally
just doesn't even try
bubble I mean like like I get not trying
the dark magic stuff but not trying like
a shrivel fig like why wouldn't you just
like be like okay we'll try it
unless there's just some major major
side effect you know
that Anne doesn't want to try
just immediately jerking it out of his
hands
and not not just like telling him no
just jerking it out of his hands
and then destroying it
get him
nope I hear another one
and if he's trapped back there
oh there's more
have I though
oh look at that all three of them
together
oh
hold on we need a wig and weld
oh there's more dude where are they all
coming from
trying to save some of my
Wigan Wells
oh my goodness glacius defendo
super powerful even this early in the
game
whoa
no not that spell
s
how do you already have that back
that Shield
I confess
that was a bit smaller than I'd bargain
that's just a bit
just a bit huh
all right so can we repair this yes we
can
don't know if that served any purpose
but hey we did it anyway
yeah she wants back out now she
seriously won't no no way
Luna
stay in here lay
just let her in she already wants that
okay what do you got for us Sebastian
loyalists deserved what they got
couldn't agree more
this is where it happened we smelt smoke
in the middle of the night when we
looked outside Flames were shooting from
the estate before my uncle and I could
stop her and rushed out racing towards
the fire worried someone would be hurt
she came face to face with a horde of
goblins frantically trying to Stamp Out
the Flames suddenly an icy voice drifted
out from somewhere in the smoke
children should be seen and not heard
a blinding blast follows am I sure can't
give her a chance to run
pretty sure pretty sure
it sounds as if the Loyalists attacked
them without cause I wouldn't put it
past them
but I'm convinced that they were trying
to hide something it may be grasping at
Billy wigs but I keep thinking that
there might be something here that could
lead me to whoever kirstan might be the
only way to learn what type of magic
harmed her which could help me find a
cure perhaps you're right
the Loyalists are everywhere but they do
seem to be spending a lot of time here
and it's likely they're hiding something
and at Rookwood Castle shall we have a
look around Rookwood Castle
they seem to have set up a specific
reason
they have stations for everything
I've heard the goblin dig sites like
these are popping up everywhere
all right so we got to do our little
it's a wonder the ministry investigation
here
always armed and ready for a fight
ranrock's loyalists
let's see I don't think there was
anything over here
oh wait
well a single
a single coin I don't know that I've
ever seen it pop up and just say one
wow
good thing I didn't really go out of my
way for that
but that's all I ever heard all right
then there should be
something else up here
my wife and I joke we need a doggie door
on the office on the office door
so she could just come and go freely
all right looks like we got a couple
things over here
a Luna Emoji yeah we do familiar
yeah wait what is this Sebastian
I've seen this before I actually think
we're maxed out on Twitch right now on
our email what do you mean when give me
a moment I'll explain in a second your
brother has a doggy door in his office
off his wall
wow that's cool
I mean I I legit I think she would
totally she would definitely use it
actually we would probably get one we
put it in and then she'd probably never
want to go in or out she would just stay
in one spot
Sebastian
over here
do you think that this is the night that
Anne was cursed
could be
but it looks to me as though this was
intentional
posture check from Anna there
revelio
Sebastian
did belong to a Hogwarts Professor
hundreds of years ago who what do you I
found a pensive that day in the
Restricted Section with a memory that
showed this house she really is a little
girl and a drought the keepers have
shown me other memories as well the girl
became a Hogwarts professor
her name was Isadora morganer is Adora
Morgan asked one there it is the keepers
like in quidditch and you found a
pensive in the library hydrate I'm not
following you I realize it's like we're
done hold on I'm not even sure I
understand it all yet
and no not like quidditch tiniest of
drops left is because they're protecting
some type of knowledge
it has to do with the vault at Gringotts
let me see if I've got this straight you
have ran Rock and Brookwood after you
because of something you found a
Gringotts where you ended up via report
key you can see traces of an ancient
magic that you think Round Rock is
trying to harness
and now you've been witnessing memories
left by Keepers oh even sebastians
belong to a Hogwarts Professor he's like
hold up it's one of these
hundreds of years ago if I didn't know
you I think you were pulling my leg it
is all a bit much isn't it when you put
it like that
the point is we both have good reason to
search this house
you for answers about what happened to
Anne and Me For answers about the
keepers
he is very snarky indeed
Someone piled this here for a reason
is it blocking something only one way to
find out oh this right here
Rebellion
let us go why bother blocking a
stairwell
there might be something here worth a
closer look
they've left all of this simply strewn
about lumos tells me they're after
something bigger
wait how did you get by how did you get
down here
the journal entry one of seven it is my
second week in the camp more arrive each
day the Muggle doctors and even some of
our own healers are doing all that they
can for them the grief is palpable the
ones who have survived the plague are
forever damaged by their loss a fever
may pass the skin May mend and Scar but
the devastating sorrow remains
I saw a man much like my father who had
lost a child I couldn't bear it I longed
to give him some shred of relief I'm
beginning to think that the others are
wrong I have the power to help these
Souls it seems as arbitrary not to help
them as it would be to rid them of their
torment
John melendrive is adores
I should hold on to this
welcome in to the new followers
oh wait this is already note two I
traveled here to learn but I longed to
help my internal struggle is
overwhelming it's as though the magic
wants to heal and I am the one
preventing it from doing so should I
lose hope will I forever regret not
having done more I cannot look into the
rise knowing that I could lessen the
burden of Heartache I saw the man
leaving camp today the one who so
reminded me of my father surely it
wouldn't hurt me hurt to help him I
could further my research of course but
that would be a fortuitous consequence
of doing something good with this
ability means these journal entries are
from isadora's travels
Rebellion
hold on what else are we supposed to do
in here
lumos
you're not going to believe this
I can see the underground under craft a
Daydream
because that happens to me too
no buddy I actually see it
I know it sounds strange honestly
nothing you say sounds strange to me
anymore fair enough
I can see the undercroft through this
stone wall as though it's a window
this has happened before I'm listening I
think it's to do with my ability to see
traces of ancient magic but
you said you didn't really understand it
and that you couldn't wield it that's
true well I'm still not sure what it all
means sort of what I do know sort of my
ability allows me to travel through
these windows I see wait
we can get straight to the undercroft
from here
ominous will be flawed we can
but perhaps best not to tell anyone else
about this for now even ominous
understood
well then invisible secret ancient magic
passageway here we come
I'm tempted to hold my breath
here we go
why hide the triptych here seems as if
something's missing a note
let's have a look
okay
Rune diagram okay we recognize the
ancient magic symbol appears
a couple of different times on there
helpful in the notes
not really it's a rune symbol
I've seen similar symbols used by the
keepers I've been thinking
lived in that house centuries ago and
ran Rock and his lot have been searching
there you said that goblins may be
wielding some form of this ancient Magic
do you think Anne was cursed by ancient
magic I can't be sure of course but
I don't think so
I didn't see any traces of it around
your sister I forgot about that part
very well
but that doesn't mean it's not ancient
Magic
there's still so much we don't know
about it true
perhaps this triptych will lead us to
answers then we'll have to unravel what
this all means
but now I need to see ominous don't
worry I won't tell him anything did I
mention that apparently Salazar
Slytherin has oh the scriptorium in
Hogwarts you did not
is it connected to our common room no
idea ominous just learned of it I'll let
you know what I find out I had no idea
our visit to Xian would unfold into all
of this
heads and that's a mess
but I'm glad you told me everything you
did
I'll be in touch
till then
all right complete main quest another
one knocked out yes that is where you
learn crucio indeed
all right guys I think that's gonna be
it for me today thank you all so much
for watching talk to you again soon